the Joe Rogan experience mm everything
that you do should be in worship so to
speak to what you're the ideal you're
trying to create right yeah and you
can't do that if you're insincere you
can't do that if you're if you're just
trying to be the packaging and not the
item yeah we were talking about that
earlier that there's too many and I
think this is part of the problem with
social medias that people are
intoxicated with this idea of having
other people think they're awesome
mm-hmm so they put out all this stuff to
make it look like you know like they're
this amazing person and you know they'll
put up these quotes and put up this [ __ ]
but it's it's not really what they're
into they just want you to think they're
into it and it comes off that way like
you get like one of my biggest pet
peeves like in and I was gonna I posted
a quote last night not a quote rather
but an image of miyamoto musashi because
I got I got into the book of five rings
again I cannot wait to hear what what
just criticism somehow came out of
nowhere to tell you what what a jerk you
were how wrong you are
I didn't pay attention but what I was
gonna criticize is I was gonna say that
I have an issue with there's a lot of
people online it's not even that I have
an issue it doesn't resonate with me
there's a better way of putting it with
thirty- there's so many people that are
posting motivational [ __ ] but they
haven't done anything true it is trying
to me I'm trying to be the packaging an
item you can do that if you feel that go
do this this is this is how you go get
it isn't what the [ __ ] have you done you
have to do something and I didn't say
this last night but this is what I meant
when I posted it like if you want to
take inspiration there's something about
the words of miyamoto musashi that are
profoundly inspirational because he's a
man who bested over 60 men in one on one
sword fight so when he's talking about
strategy where he's talking about
technique and he's talking about
preparation and you must research this
you must look into this and this is how
you go this is how you go about
attacking this is how this is how you
play off your opponent strategy
he's talking about life or death
with a [ __ ] sword can't get more
serious and that comes through in his
words men even translation from Japanese
to English even though it's 400 years
later there's something about that guy
that it gives me goosebumps man when I
read his [ __ ] all I I fell in love with
samurai philosophy a long time ago from
what Neto Bay and the hagakure and
there's even one called a Bhutto or
Samurai philosophy of the samurais it's
I forget the name of it but it's a
really short succinct book that really
nails down some things and I think part
of why what they have to say is so so so
authentic and so so real so to speak is
because it's life or death for them
reading a storm of seal by Ernst younger
and you're reading this guy's take on
being in World War one and it's not that
he was never afraid it's not that he
didn't understand what war is it's just
by him from his position as a soldier
and the way he approached things in the
way he even still saw beauty in these
moments in living in that part of his
life it's it's clearly somebody that
that I believe has a good grip on being
towards death as Heidegger would put it
like being embracing what it means to be
alive and by embracing that you're also
embracing the fact that you are gonna
die it is not going away that that death
is alongside you and you don't know when
it's coming and there's no need to
because you're not supposed to be
thinking about whether or not you're
gonna die or when it's gonna come or
anything like that but you're you need
to be thinking about what you're gonna
do before that time does show up and how
you're gonna do it and for why you know
what is it how are you finding meaning
and fulfillment in life so that when
when death comes along and tugs on your
shoulder and on your shirt sleeve you're
like all right well this is it yeah and
those guys people that you've described
whether it's Musashi or any of those
people but what comes out in their words
is authenticity
because of the fact that they have led
these extraordinary lives and they have
faced incredible danger they have lived
there's there's something about that
where you can genuinely learn from those
people whereas
there's a lot of people that really
haven't but they know that people long
for those things so they try to recreate
it we try to recreate these quotes or
they try to find some words that will
inspire you to get going in and seize
the moment and make the most of the the
day and go out there and conquer and
write and kick ass and you know it
doesn't mean it's all persona it is
attempting to take on its presenting the
persona of that kind of individual
mainly because they know that deep down
all of us realized that there's weight
to those kind of yes you know and I'm
sure Peterson would be like it's the
bloody archetype
[Applause]